uh one thing i'd maybe
want to ask on that is and maybe to push
back a little bit so there's the jerk
side
but there's also if i were to criticize
what i've seen in silicon valley
which is almost the resistance to
working hard
so on the jerkiness side is um
it's it's so posted jobs and elon kind
of
push people to work really hard to do
and it's a question whether it's
possible to do that nicely
but one of the things that bothers me
maybe i'm just rushing
and just kind of you know romanticize
the whole suffering thing
but i think working hard is essential
for accomplishing anything interesting
like really hard and in the parlance of
silicon valley it's probably too hard
this idea that you should work smart not
hard
often uh to me sounds like you should be
lazy
because of course you want to be to work
smart of course you want to be
maximally efficient but in order to
discover the efficient path like we're
talking about the short programs
yeah well you know the the
the smart hard thing yeah isn't an
either or
it's an and as an and yeah right
and um you know the the
the the the the people who say you
should work smart
not hard they pretty much always fail
yeah thank you right i mean that's
that's that's just just a recipe for
disaster i mean there are
there are counter examples but
they're more people who benefited from
luck
and you're saying yeah exactly luck and
timing like you said is
often uh an essential thing but you're
saying you know
you can be you can push people to work
hard and do incredible work without
without uh without being nasty yeah
without being nasty
i think uh um
google is a good example of the
leadership of google throughout his
history has been
a pretty good example of uh not being
nasty
i mean the the the the twins
larry and sergey um are both pretty nice
people
sandra paches very nice yeah yeah
yeah and you know it's it's a cultural
of people who
work really really hard
you